oh yeah without fever welcome to Philly
you're to a Tuesday now get you a soft
friend some water ice in your salad
hey man unbelievable
the World Cup may be over but not here
Jessie's gonna love Oh
what's your name man what wasn't kawatte
a
let it go feed I said no
even with Steve
those are the famous rocky steps but I'm
Way more interested in that this is bad
hang out Steve are you pushing yourself
he's gonna be
ah you're maybe not over no see I
couldn't do that
that's too gnarly man yeah you want to
bite whoo
I need to get a watch not it
no it's moving steam oh it's moving it's
moving no I swear to God
Stephen
oh my god
whoa whoa
you crazy [ __ ] alright we'll run
up
yeah that's in pipi Longstocking haha
where's my date I'm so glad you're here
I know it's like Marin Cecilia third
wheel tonight yeah
April did you just say which ban would
change clothes well actually maybe I
think I mean I have a great day thanks
Ken damn back to what he was I just have
to do this quick tribute to ed
Bassmaster because I love them so much
I'm here at the helium comedy club in
Philadelphia it might be my favorite
comedy club in the world
let me Mull it over here we are leaving
the airport but don't worry we'll be
back in seven and a half hours for how a
long flight to doctor Australia
it's not gonna be Martin Short at all
yeah takes a while to get to down Carrie
Underwood home for a very short time
I'll be damned if I'm not gonna spend it
with my
beautiful children
if you're watching this you probably
came over from Jesse's channel thank you
guys I want you to subscribe right here
because I'm never gonna waste your time
if you don't know who Jesse is you
probably don't know a whole lot about
YouTube if anything at all Jesse and
Edie bassmaster are both legends and
heroes of mine please subscribe to both
of their channels and watch Jesse's
version of the same events right here
yeah dude [ __ ] age of the selfie
power